welcome at Z headquarters home of the
online market that's revolutionized the
way arts and crafts are sold across the
world
Etsy's Brooklyn office pays homage to
the 1 million craftspeople who sell on
its site everything in the office tables
chairs light fixtures art came full
price from Etsy sellers overhead there's
a yarn-bombing
installation yarn-bombing installation
Etsy and its 60 employees moved into
this Brooklyn warehouse in 2009 today
its square footage has swelled from
15,000 to 80,000 and its head count
stands at 350 I want everyone to feel a
sense of community I think that's really
important and it's harder because you
know this office is getting bigger and
bigger one way at seek justice
keep it real is through eat see keep see
is a program where we have locally
catered food delicious food brought in
twice a week and we all eat at the same
time
you always get to meet new people and
the different conference rooms are the
different lunch tables are I think one
of my favorite stories about ETSU no
certain site features have come about
because of eat see conversations the
people in this office aren't just
employees they're Etsy sellers two dozen
so their crafts on the site and
employees host creative classes for one
another we have had crocheting classes
and knitting classes I did an enamel in
class so I got to make the circuit
Chad Dickerson is the executive force
behind Etsy he took over a CEO in 2011
under his leadership Etsy has added 20
million members and merchandise sales
doubled how do you balance with getting
really big and significant and staying
true to your brand at the end of the day
when you buy on Etsy it's a person
buying from another person so the very
nature of the transaction is really
based on personal intimacy so as we grow
I think as long as we maintain that
sense of personal intimacy that no
matter how large as he gets you'll still
have the sense of intimacy in the
platform but how big you want to grow do
you want an IPO on your own I think one
outcome threats it could be being a
public company but I think in many ways
that's just a legal structure I think
the the way we think about it is just
being independent and serving the
community
[Music]
you